[Music]
we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we've got turf set white tie tabata yoga
and boot camp it's your body
this is fighting I am Tyler and I'm a
disciple of more time
[Music]
this is your at home my tie warm-up hey
guys we're here with Tyler who's going
to run us through a Muay thai-style
warmup so talk to me Tyler what are we
what are we warming up here well when we
do a more Thai style warm-up we want to
try to just get the body moving get the
blood flowing try to get the joints
loose and just get your whole body
moving as much as we can before we
really engage in some hardcore activity
normally I like to warm up with with
jumping jacks in general you want to
make sure that when you do your jumping
jacks that your feet don't go too wide
and that your body pressure doesn't for
shinee's in so we want to make sure that
our hands and feet work together which
is kind of the combination of one type
because your hands if you don't working
together as our as our feet kick Ally
our hands above our head so we just make
sure our fingers touch make sure if you
don't go wider than shoulders too much
and come back and forth try to breathe
through your nose as long as you can
okay so you become out of breath and you
can go ahead and redo your mouth okay so
two minutes okay set go you can adjust
your speed a little fast a little slower
depending on how you feel we're looking
to get about 120 in two minutes you got
to go a little faster and break
good go ahead shake it off and shake
your arms out shake it legs out what
we're going to start doing is a shadow
boxing okay shadow boxing is the
foundation for you to kind of program
your mind to move to react so what we
start is by going into our fighting
stance like we did before we put both
feet together start here we'll turn one
foot out 90 degrees we'll separate a
little bit a little wide then we bring
that right hand up to my chin let's see
now in front of me and then you just
practice breathing and then throwing
your punches and then you can start
adding different stuff to those punches
and remember we do it slow
we don't want to snap that joint out to
where your elbow locks you're almost
pushing and pulling your punches it's
just more to get that to get your body
moving and get your blood pumped up a
little bit you can also change your
punches you can go to
uppercuts you can throw hook you can
bring that left knee straight up point
your toe down okay that would be a
blocking technique as well the offensive
technique and when you bring that left
knee up you lean back on that right foot
there you go
as you warm up and you become a little
warmer you want to punch a little faster
put a little more speed into your
punches with a move
your head go ahead and break go ahead
shake it out relax take a minute off you
feel yourself loosen up a little bit
more now that yeah we're work okay good
you just keep shaking it out all right
guys well to recap this is our muy Thai
style warm-up we started off with two
minutes of jumping jacks and then we
finished up with some shadow boxing
again about a minute two minutes of that
just to get your body warm loose it's
very important to get this warm-up in
you don't want to start cold listen your
body something hurts other than a good
sore like a muscle soreness stop don't
overtrain get some rest so don't just
jump right into whatever exercise you're
doing that day take the time to warm up
properly definitely make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
other fighting weight episodes
[Music]